make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so for those of you guys who are
fans of the boys those videos are coming
out later on today so don't worry I'm
not gonna leave you guys hanging on that
the big thing about this the big
announcement that I have to make here we
are at almost 10,000 subscribers on my
personal Instagram account at I am rob
Jefferson at the time that we're
recording I think we're in like nine
thousand nine hundred and sixty
something so once we crossed 10k I'm
gonna give away five Rob four rings one
Rob pour ring every day over the course
of five days if you want to win one then
go to my personal Instagram account
follow it and keep an eye on it because
what I'll do is I'll drop a video there
basically tells you exactly what it is
that I'm going to do and how it is that
you can win one of those rings
having said that those of you guys who
are on patreon for the rod core rings
there's gonna be a video for you there
so so don't worry like you guys are all
gonna be sorted out I'm where I'm not
gonna leave you guys all hanging and
everything I think that's a really
really really going to like what it is
at you here but in this video we're
picking up with the the battle between
Adam Brashear the blue Marvel and
Hyperion now here's the thing right
because I was kind of on the fence about
this before I was like maybe we should
do this maybe we shouldn't but we're
going to and the reason why is because
you guys really seem to love Adam
Brashear right like you guys love the
blue Marvel I don't really know why
honestly there are there are times that
I make videos on my channel I don't even
really care whether or not the video
performs I just do it because I like it
right I don't really care about the
views I'm just like it'd be cool that's
all I'm gonna do it it's the reason why
I'm doing the doing the boys the video
performs terribly on my youtube channel
but I love the video but I love that
story so I love recording it but here's
the thing all right so this is actually
a short story right this is not a full
comic book so it's not like 22 pages
instead this is more like eight pages
and the reason why is because this comes
out of something called the Age of
Heroes now for those guys who are
familiar with with morals Marvel's you
know heroic age bear with me for a
second right because I know a lot of you
guys were reading Marvel for a long time
and a lot of you guys are really aware
of this this is more for the new fans so
so we we've talked a whole bunch of
times about how my joke asada took over
Marvel in the early 2000s and the chief
creative officer and gave us stories
like House of M and Spider Man one more
day and like Avengers disassembled
things like that it was designed to kind
of be this grand reshuffling of Marvel
right and it worked for the most part I
mean I guess we're the exception to
spider-man fans are still kind of angry
about that but for most everything else
it worked exceedingly well but the idea
was once this whole reshuffling was done
did it was time to go back into being
heroes again right so that's why
everything kind of got really really
dark you into Dark Reign with Norman
Osborn and all that kind of cool stuff
the heroic age followed all that so that
was an initiative that came out in 2010
2011 and it was basically the hero's
going back to being heroes as they were
really in like the classic era of comics
right so it's when those things worse
like this great big huge ten year long
epic by that was rugged really kind of
spearheaded by Joe Quesada that got to
the heroic age what Marvel did in turn
is they released four one shots called
the Age of Heroes and these are
basically just miniseries about
characters who otherwise wouldn't have
gotten a normal book and Adam Brashear
was one of them so what this does is
immediately come hot off the heels of
Adam the legend of blue marvels those
are guys who read his original story by
Kevin Gravano this immediately comes
directly after that not like the next
day but in terms of you know chronology
and what it does is it basically picks
up in the Mariana Trench which is where
blue Marvel operates out of right that's
his base of operations more or less and
he's actually being visited by who watch
you The Watcher and the reason why is
because Adam Brashear is stuck in a
conflict right with everything that
happened at the ledge after The Legend
of blue Marvel and the fact that he
returned essentially to be a superhero
the question is like is this a superhero
landscape and his idea is really kind of
looking around and saying everybody's
afraid of heroes now this is designed to
be both meta textual as well as income
to book continuity right when I say meta
I mean like it's really a demurrer kind
of referencing the publication history
of Marvel for the ten years that kind of
led up to this as well as the in
continuity landscape right you know in
the end continuity landscape this is
basically a place where everybody is
afraid of heroes like you literally had
a vendor's disassembled so Tony Stark
basically appeared before the United
Nations drunk although it ended up being
that it was a Scarlet Witch who
manipulated his mind into appearing that
way
The Scarlet Witch then turn around and
launched a massive assault against
Avengers mansion
Hawkeye died right so that was like the
whole of New York was freaking out over
that didn't you go into the events of
house of M where 98% of the mutant
population loses their powers I mean you
have like a lot of these really really
charged stories and so the result is a
humanity doesn't really trust
superheroes but the response of who
watts who is yes but like you are a
unique person like your your unique
insofar as you don't have the same kind
of powers or at least the same kind of
basis as anybody else
you're literally a one-man wrecking crew
right like you're powered by antimatter
energy now to give you guys some
perspective on this to kind of give you
guys an understanding of this basically
imagine like a lot of the guys probably
heard of the negative zone right the
negative zone is this dimension that's
basically antimatter right the opposite
of positive matter being that if
positive and antimatter hit you would
creat like this kind of explosive
explosive reaction
imagine that there was a portal that led
to the negative zone and imagine out of
that portal was just energy constantly
flowing out and imagine all that energy
was entering into Adam Brashear that's
basically what he is he channels
antimatter energy long story short Adam
Bashir is powered by the energy of a
universe of like an entire universe
that's basically how powerful this guy
is and as that's the reason why we watch
The Watcher says you single-handedly
have the ability to change the way that
humanity views superheroes one because
of your story and two because of the
power that you possess the issue with
that is that in the middle of all this
what you end up having is is basically
all these you know these guys who were
essentially taken out by Hyperion right
by King Hyperion who's just kind of
appeared here it's not here in an is
Uzbekistani and now it's kind of
interesting because what he's doing is
facing off against the winter guard the
winter guard to suck all right let's
just be honest with ourselves nobody out
there believes the winter guard is a
great team and they're capable they're
Russia's superhero team they're awful
but one of the things that goes on here
is that the system of Adam Brashear
identifies King Hyperion as a I guess a
level 12 threat now the reason why this
matters is because in Marvel Comics you
have different measuring systems that
kind of determine the threat level of a
particular person or team right in in
the mutant population you have Omega
level and Beyond Omega level in terms of
shield and government depictions you
have Omega level threats right and then
without ever sheer it's just threat
level it's just kind of straightforward
right now the fact that Hyperion is
depicted as as a lot as a level 12
threat means he's a threat of the
highest caliber so of course Adam
Brashear races off and Adam Beshear goes
to goes to fight the guy now the thing
about this is that as soon as they get
to his Becca stand you give this
explanation of what it is us going on
with King Hyperion but the funny thing
about this is that unless you read
exiles you only get part of the picture
here right like you only really get part
of the story and the reason why that
matters is because King Hyperion this is
not his first appearance at Marvel
Comics
King Hyperion appeared as part of the
Exile storyline for quite some time and
the way this played out here by virtue
of whatever Gerber says here as well as
what was revealed in exiles I think was
like issues 43 running all the way up to
like 65 or something like that is that
basically in an alternate reality
Hyperion essentially rose up and then
like tried to conquer the world and all
the various superheroes across the world
ended up facing off against Hyperion and
he killed them all but he killed every
single one of Earth's super heroes there
was never really confirmed she's kind of
what he said he also killed Galactus in
that universe and so following that over
time he and
joining a group called Weapon X now this
is not the same weapon action what the
main Marvel Universe right the group
that like produced Wolverine and so on
and so forth instead this was kind of a
team that was the antithesis to the
Exiles insofar as the Weapon X group
under really under the rule of King
Hyperion which also included like Miss
Marvel included spider-man so on and so
forth these alternate reality versions
of their characters would travel from
one universe to the next and conquer
those world so I conquer various
versions of Earth's destroy the
superheroes on them or force them to
work for their cause whatever the case
was and this is just the most recent
iteration this is where he shows up here
so it's kind of a cool thing because
this guy King Hyperion is insanely
powerful right like powerful enough to
kill Galactus which is kind of a big
thing and that becomes important here in
a second the reason why is because as
soon as blue Marvel shows up and
confronts King Hyperion the first thing
he says is I've killed you on countless
worlds right like you're nothing new to
me I've destroyed you on multiple worlds
multiple times before I'm not worried
about you and the funny thing about it
is that blue Marvel is kind of holding
back here and the reason why is because
there's all these innocent people around
here different things like that
but of course King Hyperion keeps coming
on to the offensive and the other half
of this is that blue marble is kind of
struggling with the fact of like I don't
want to scare the people who are here
right like I don't want to scare them
here but what he is up doing is coming
to this realization that the reality of
what it means to be a superhero is that
in the beginning people will be scared
because you're showing up to a place
where they've never really seen
superheroes before right it's one of the
things that he says here is these people
who are scared because there are places
on earth where they have no superheroes
there's no superheroes to protect their
country or anything like that that most
of the superheroes exist in like large
metropolitan areas right I mean they
exist in like San Francisco or they
exist in in Los Angeles they exist
largely in New York but for the most
part most of these people have only ever
heard of super-powered beings and never
actually came face to face with one and
that's the reason they're scared not
really because of the fact that that
Adam Brashear is dangerous or anything
like that and so understanding that and
and really kind of like reconciling at
what he is up saying is like okay well
that's the case you know if at the end
of the day Hyperion would go through and
kill everybody then let's just in this
quick fast and in a hurry so literally
in the span of like 3 hits blue marvels
just like Bam Bam Bam King Hyperion's
defeated it's the quickest and ever it's
insane I mean look at this look at this
like they go they go charging at each
other right so that's hit number one so
I guess maybe four hits where they go
charging at each other and that's hit
number one so so then he like he
uppercuts him he punches him in the face
and then he smashes him into the ground
done select four hits and King Hyperion
is down a guy who was powerful enough to
kill Galactus is taken out and like
three or four hits by Adam Brashear he
was so overpowered and broken
minimisation do I love Adam Brashear do
I love the new marvel we need blue
Marvel in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that's just that's just the way it is
man because you're talking about a guy
who's this powerful and then he's also
super smart right he's got degrees like
theoretical physics and all that kind of
stuff I don't even know what that means
I don't even know what theoretical
physics mean things that we think might
exist so we're gonna do science on
things that we think might exist like I
don't I don't understand that man like
for me you might as well tell me that
you're doing science experiments on the
possibilities that dragons are real it's
funny and it's wild to see Hyperion
crushed so fast so handedly by blue
Marvel just crushed so readily and so
again like that's that's really what it
is because following that he kind of
starts hopping and skipping through I
like a lot of these smaller towns that
don't have any superheroes within their
own country right I mean you know he
goes like Singapore for example
Singapore has no superheroes Ecuador
doesn't really have superheroes Paris
doesn't really have superheroes of
course I don't know what what French
superheroes would do I mean they would
probably just surrender as soon as a
threat showed up because that's what the
fridge people do but nonetheless it's
kind of wild right it's it's coming it's
a cool thing to see and it's awesome to
watch this whole thing go down but
that's basically where it ends ready you
know it's almost like every Griffo kind
of takes this page out of Superman peace
on earth we're like Superman's traveling
from one country to the next trying to
like you know basically improve things
without like casting off dictators
killing people different things like
that it's awesome to see but this is
basically how you transition from blue
Marvel in terms of where he was at the
end of Adam the legend of blue marvel
intellect the main Marvel Universe and
then it goes forward from there and
ultimately leads up to ultimate so it is
a pretty cool little story here again Oh
something like eight or nine pages long
it's not super lengthy it's pretty short
and it's pretty fast but it is really
really really cool so with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you guys are new here to
come and explain it make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]